now that the time masters are gone
history has been left unguarded
everything that has happened or will
happen is subject to the exploitation of
time criminals which is why history
needs new protectors it needs legends
my name is Rex Tyler I'm a member of the
Justice Society of America
Babloo past the point of worrying about
the timeline
I need to talk to you about the legends
I think they're all in trouble
somebody just blew up New York during
World War two think we can all go
through that someone is Nazis I hate
Nazis it's not like the time masters are
here to stop her
we are history's last line of defense
relax captain we got this
I've been waiting a long time for this a
long time for what to kill you
are you uh sure you know how to fly this
thing let's find out
you
oh my god youtubers they are fully going
Legion of Doom versus Justice Society on
legends of tomorrow so I'm gonna break
the trailer down and explain what they
announced the comic-con so there are a
bunch of big announcements about legends
of tomorrow season two in case you
missed it season two is going to be all
about the Justice Society but the big
surprise of comic-con was the other
characters that they confirm were going
to be a part of that star girl obsidian
doctor midnight commander steel and
vixen so they are doing a [ __ ] ton of
Justice Society characters and you know
even bigger surprise in my mind was when
they announced that you know you have a
big hero team-up you have to have
villains to match that so they are going
to do the most comic book thing possible
villain team-up Legion of Doom that
team's gonna be Malcolm Merlyn Captain
Cold
the eobard thawne reverse-flash and
damian darhk-- I know a lot of you are
asked ok so just careful for spoilers
from arrow to season there was some big
twist with those characters this year so
damian darhk-- was killed by oliver at
the end of arrow season 4 but when they
said he was going to be part of the
Legion of Doom they said you know the
asterisk is that he will be from the
1940s so even though the main focus of
season 2 is gonna be this big Justice
Society art going up against the Legion
of Doom they're going to be jumping
around in time as they try to stop them
so a lot of that's going to be set up in
the first episode I think there's
supposed to be a flashback with damian
darhk-- in the 1940s so that will tee up
their Legion of Doom arc we had the
teaser at the end of season 1 where our
man shows up and says I'm part of the
Justice Society so it just feels like
they're making the TV show that you
wanted it to be in season 1 there were
some really good moments in legend
season 1 but it was a little uneven so I
feel like now they've gotten to the
point where they can do this bigger
comic book story and maybe it has some
stuff to do with what's going on behind
the scenes like the the production of it
all the way the organized contracts the
way that DC lets them use characters so
you may have heard the really cool news
that John Barrowman Wentworth Miller the
people that play Captain Cold and
Malcolm Merlyn signed big contracts to
be regulars on all of the DC TV shows it
was like this big overall contract just
meaning that they're going to show up on
each of the four TV shows so you have
Supergirl you have legends of tomorrow
you have flash and arrow so there are a
couple actors that have contracts like
that that will just be jumping around
from
to show the newest one they they just
announced to get a deal like that is
Katie Cassidy now they didn't exactly
say how Katie Cassidy is going to
crossover with all the four TV shows
because we know that she's going to
continue to be in flashbacks and air so
when we see her on arrow she'll be a
younger version of the character who
hasn't become black hair yet but when
she appears on legends of tomorrow or
like when she goes on supergirls she
might do birds of prey so they haven't
explained it so just like wide open to
speculation but Katie Cassidy is gonna
be jumping around and on top of that the
reverse-flash will be a series regular
on legends of tomorrow meaning he's
gonna be in most of the episodes but he
won't be a serious regular on the flash
season 3
he's only again appear in the first
couple of episodes and then maybe again
later in the season but there's gonna be
a whole bunch of reverse-flash because
of this Legion of Doom Archaean because
of flashpoint things that are going on
in the flash I'm actually more excited
about the reverse-flash than I am about
the other Legion of Doom characters what
about Jay Garrick though he was a
founding member of the Justice Society
so of course it makes sense that they
would try to use him on that TV show
so John Wesley Shipp the actor really
only confirmed that he was coming back
for the flash season 3 he said that he's
spoken to the producers about legends of
tomorrow and all they've really said is
is that they can do a lot more with the
character like they can actually bring
him on to legends of tomorrow but they
haven't written that story yet so
they're like we're really excited to
write it so he will in the future
they just haven't confirmed which
episode he's gonna appear in how it's
gonna work
so tentatively just assume that you will
see Jay Garrick Justice Society things
happening during season 2 which i think
is actually way better than having Barry
Allen a crossover that is one of the
biggest questions that you guys were
asking me earlier this year what legends
of tomorrow season one what's happening
when will the flash appear on legends of
tomorrow so if you were on the fence
about legends of tomorrow season one or
if you quit during the middle of the
season because you didn't like the
Hawkman Hawkgirl storyline they are
going to be none of those shenanigans in
season 2 it will be hardcore justice
society vs Legion of Doom and I know a
lot of you are asking about Constantine
so Matt Ryan actually did the voice for
Constantine in the Justice League dark
animated movie now if you don't know
anything about that like they have the
animated DC movies like they did Justice
League war they did throne of Atlantis
so like the latest movie to exist in
that universe that they just made
is Justice League dark is just like the
comic book if you read that during the
new 52 it looks more like the new 52
version of Justice League dark Matt
Ryan's Constantine appears in that movie
I don't know exactly when it's coming
out but it's not connected to any of the
TV shows but I think they're slowly
opening the door for him to guest star
and if he's willing to do the voice of
the character in an animated movie yes I
totally think that he's willing to come
back and do legends of tomorrow I think
you know the funny thing in all this is
they announced so much stuff at Comic
Con but you really don't get any of that
from the footage in this trailer like
you just see the same old team so if you
like the trailer itself isn't that great
like they're completely burying the lede
they aren't showing off any of this
awesome Justice League or Legion of Doom
stuff but I think the reason for that is
because they didn't start production
till a little bit after a flash and
arrow started select flash and arrow are
almost at episode 3 so they had a whole
bunch of footage to show off a comic-con
legends of tomorrow and Supergirl didn't
start production till only recently so
they probably haven't shot a whole lot
of stuff so that's probably why you
didn't see any Justice Society stuff in
this trailer let me know what you guys
think about the idea of Justice Society
vs. Legion of Doom in season 2 I feel
like that's what the show needs that is
what the show should have been in season
1 but just a real quick reminder there
is a new round of the DC giveaway that's
been going on it's still open
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'm gonna be doing some more
Marvel stuff next then I'll do an arrow
season 5 trailer video I'll just
announce the winner when I post that
trailer video so get AI for Justice
Society and actually you know another
big question let me know who do you
think is gonna be the most evil member
of the Legion of Doom as evil as the
reverse-flash is it is going to be
really hard for him to out evil Malcolm
Merlyn well you guys wait for me to post
that you can click here for my breakdown
to the Thor Ragnarok teaser that they
showed off and you can click here for my
breakdown of the guardians of the galaxy
to footage thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight